in die Abstimmung ist offensichtlich
ausgezählt jetzt müssen sich die
Abgeordneten alle wieder hinsetzen Platz
nehmen damit dann das Ergebnis verkündet
werden kann wir wollen mal reinhören und
Immunisierung der Bevölkerung gegen
saßkow 2 in der ausschussfassung
Drucksachen 20 899 20 954 und 20
1.353
abgegebene Stimmkarten 683 mit ja haben
gestimmt 296
mit Nein haben gestimmt
Enthaltungen 9 der Gesetzentwurf ist in
zweiter Beratung abgelehnt damit
entfällt nach unserer Geschäftsordnung
die weitere Beratung dieses
Gesetzentwurfs
wir gehen dann weiter
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen eine
gewisse Ernsthaftigkeit bei einem
solchen Thema wäre jetzt aber auch
angebracht
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt weiter zur Abstimmung
über den Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
auf Drucksache 978 mit dem Titel im
vorsorgegesetz ein guter Schutz für
unser Land es ist namentliche Abstimmung
verlangt
die Schriftführerin und Schriftführer
sind an ihren Plätzen die Uhren sind
besetzt ich eröffne die namentliche
Abstimmung für 10 Minuten bitte
sehen Sie zu dass sie zügig ihre Stimme
abgeben vielen Dank
[Musik]
Bild breaking news
so sie haben es gehört Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer das war
eine ganz klare Abstimmung die
Impfpflicht ab 60 sie würden nicht
kommen Jan wow das ist schon harter
Tobago das ist eine superklatsche für
Karl Lauterbach vor allem weil sie auch
so deutlich jetzt ausgefallen ist also
ich lese es noch mal vor 683 abgegebene
Stimmen da fehlen knapp 50 also 50
Abgeordnete sind offenbar nicht da und
die der der Vorschlag der meisten Ampel
abgeordne muss man ja sagen der
Kompromissvorschlag hinter dem auch der
Bundesgesundheitsminister stand und der
Bundeskanzler hat ganze 296 Stimmen
bekommen 378 also fast 100 mehr der
Abgeordneten haben mit Nein gestimmt es
gab 9 Enthaltungen das ist eine super
Klatsche das ist ganz klar Karl
Lauterbach muss man sagen ist mit dem
ganzen Thema Impfpflicht komplett
gescheitert mit dem heutigen Tag schwarz
auf weiß das haben wir jetzt gesehen und
was wird jetzt genau noch abgestimmt
jetzt geht's weiter ganz genau jetzt
kommt der zweitweite skende
impfpflichtantrag das ist der von
cdu/csu eingegeben und 200 Abgeordnete
stellt die cdu/csu nur noch in dem
aktuellen Bundestag und der hat
mutmaßlich auch wenig Chance
durchzugehen aber das ein Antrag der
gesagt hat wir wollen erst ein
impfregister und halten uns vor dass wir
im Herbst dann zu einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht kommen wenn wir feststellen
okay ähm die coronazahlen geht wieder
deutlich rauf also das ist so ein auf
Vorrat impfpflichtantrag kann man sagen
dem würde ich jetzt auch überhaupt keine
Chancen einräumen denn es müssten jetzt
ja viele aus der Ampelkoalition
abstimmen diese mutmaßlich ziemlich
frustriert also ich glaube dass man da
jetzt auch zu keinem positiven Ergebnis
kommt es wäre wenn es so wäre ein super
Triumph für Friedrich Merz auf der
anderen Seite aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass gerade die SPD
Abgeordnete jetzt sagen nein dem Stimme
bewusst nicht zu um nicht diese Klatsche
für Olaf Scholz und dieses super Debakel
für Lauterbach dann zusätzlich zu einem
Sieg für Friedrich Merz umzumünzen also
ganz da zum Festhalten super Klatsche
für Karl Lauterbach meiner Meinung nach
ist das für
Gesundheitsminister dann in dem Amt auch
nicht weiter tragbar also für ihn nicht
dass da das ist der bricht jetzt
wirklich etwas zusammen vor Olaf Scholz
ist das eine Niederlage muss man so
deutlich sagen und wir sehen wer heute
dann als lächelnder Sieger rausgeht
vielleicht ist es Wolfgang Kubicki der
von Anfang an gegen die Impfpflicht war
was bedeutet das denn auch für den
Zusammenhang der Ampel muss man sagen
dass dieses Thema jetzt die neue
Regierung ja schon spaltet sehr früh das
ist in der Tat eine sehr gute Frage das
wird sicherlich aufzuarbeiten sein denn
wir haben von vielen Prominenten Ampel
Abgeordneten oder auch Ministern ja
gehört dass sie sich für die Impfpflicht
ausgesprochen haben auch Robert habe
Katja im Vorwahlkampf gesagt also wenn
es richtig also dass sie sich eigentlich
dann im Endeffekt auch für eine
Impfpflicht aussprechen die also dass da
gab es schon viele viele Befürworter
aber wir stellen fest es hat bei weitem
nicht gereicht